en matière d'immigration il ne peut pas
y avoir de en même temps où vous voulez
plus d'immigration où vous voulez moins
d'immigration dans notre pays nous
députés les républicains nous voulons
moins d'immigration en France car nos
capacités d'intégration ont depuis
longtemps largement dépasser le seuil de
saturation vous vous voulez toujours
plus d'immigration dans notre pays à la
star de ces 5 dernières années record du
nombre de demandeurs d'asile record du
nombre de titres de séjour délivrés
record du nombre de clandestins record
d'inexécution des auqtf votre bilan est
désastreux pour reprendre les mots de
Gérard Collomb en matière d'immigration
50 perdus en proposant une vague de
régularisation massive de travailleurs
clandestins qui demain seront éligibles
regroupement familial Votre gouvernement
poursuit son chemin sur la voie de la
lâcheté et de la facilité en faisant de
l'immigration la solution à tous les
dysfonctionnements du marché du travail
au lieu de remettre au travail ou en
formation les cinq que 5 millions de
chômeurs déjà présents dans notre pays
pour pouvoir l'une des 300 000 offres
vacantes vous préférez vous incliner
devant les suppliques du patronat plutôt
que de vous interroger sur les raisons
qui poussent certains chômeurs à refuser
de reprendre un travail ou sur celle qui
font de la France l'avant dernier pays
de en ce qui concerne l'inadéquation
entre besoins et offre de formation il
existe cependant un chemin vers la
reprise en main notre politique
migratoire mais pour cela il vous faut
du courage diminuer et drastiquement
l'immigration familiale et étudiante qui
sont devenues des trappes à
clandestinités puis à bas salaire pensez
d'une immigration familiale subit sous
qualifiée à une immigration choisie sur
qualifiée comme le font les autres pays
obtenez enfin les laisser passer
consulaires nécessaires aux expulsions
en tordant le bras des pays d'origine
des clandestins en supprimant les visas
les publics au développement et les
transferts d'argent vers ces pays alors
madame la Première ministre êtes-vous
enfin prête à abandonner le en même
temps migratoire à faire preuve de
courage et à écouter nos propositions